so you got a pitch meeting for me yes
sir i do it's for squid game he's going
to speak korean this entire pitch beam
it's going to be subtitled i know a good
amount of people actually watch the dub
with this why would you do that for
yourself thank you so much for clicking
on this video by the way uh we're going
to be putting out a special video this
weekend uh regarding squid game haven't
told john about this yet when you first
hear this you might gawk your eyes at
this you might be like please god no i
think after you hear out what i gotta
say especially
and perhaps maybe what john has to say
too you might go
maybe casting the american remake oh
sweet
i'm excited for that for the challenge
yes it's going to be really good we're
going to come up with the definitive
caps you guys are going to wish you
could say
[Music]
so you have a new series for me yes sir
i do well actually this comes from our
team in south korea oh interesting now
are you korean i'm not no okay and
you're sure yes cause you know you look
like someone i might cast to play an
asian character yeah
and you know please stop doing that kind
of thing well no promises so tell me
about this show well sir it's called
squid game okay so this is like in the
shark tale cinematic universe well
actually no sir because that's not a
thing that exists interesting
interesting yeah so this is a show where
a bunch of desperate people play in
children's games for sure to win a bunch
of money how much money are we talking
45.6 billion wow south korean won
which is also a lot in us dollars okay
great awesome so we're going to follow
this guy named gee hun right okay and he
owes a bunch of money to loan sharks
yeah from shark tail nope and so after a
guy in a suit slaps him around in a
subway station a little bit he gets
invited to participate in this event
that can help him clear his debt oh
getting slapped around by a guy in a
suit is tight okay and so he gets picked
up in this van and some gas knocks him
unconscious and he wakes up in this
weird place with a bunch of other people
oh boy and so what's the deal with this
place well everybody's in a numbered
track suit and there are very angry
playstation buttons watching everybody
what snow x's that was an aesthetic
choice that i feel like they had to have
known that people would be going there
with it right yeah cause that was the
first thing you said yeah you see the
card and they're all rinded up together
and you're like it looks just like lazy
and then i remember not laughing because
i was like i bet john's not the first
person to make that joke which means
that joke's old jawed yeah come up with
new materials i know i'm so sorry when
in reality this is only the second time
i've heard this [ __ ]
and the first time was for me so what
what so then these 456 players go into
this other area to play a big game a red
light green light and what's that ah
well see you can only move forward when
this massive horrifying doll isn't
looking at you oh my god and if the doll
sees you move you get shot and killed
wait what is this show some people start
freaking out and running around and 255
people get brutally murdered what is
happening what is going on
this is a super secret organization with
insane surveillance and if you lose in a
game you die oh very messed up yeah it
also turns out this cop who's following
a lead on his missing brother he's
infiltrating this whole operation man
that's gonna be hard to do with all the
crazy surveillance actually it's gonna
be super easy barely an inconvenience oh
really yeah he just sneaks onto this
boat that's bringing players to this
place and he kills one of the
playstation buttons and puts his uniform
and mask on he just kills someone at the
beginning of the investigation yes he
doesn't even know what's going on yet
yeah so he just does a casual little
murder because he needs the right
clothes to keep investigating that is
such a good point i never thought about
that yeah i mean it's clear some fishy
is going on but at that point to just
murder a guy yes a little much i mean i
don't really know if maybe in korea
they're like yeah it happens all the
time there's a bunch of badass cops and
he is the most bruce will to see
character out of the mall he's the only
like action hero going to the mall he is
die hard and the show's already showing
us how just god-awful these people are
but was he made privy to anything that
was truly awful other than the mass
amount of people being gassed in the
vans yeah i mean that was bad that was
pretty bad i mean he seems to at least
have some inkling for like the the
legendary existence of this game so
maybe he just drew some conclusions that
killing's okay killing's okay and then
he just kind of goes with the flow and
pretends that he works there from there
on out and it keeps working so he's like
good at improv passable at best he keeps
being like hey what are you guys talking
about and the other guards are like you
know what we're talking about we're
there for the thing we're talking about
very suspicious yeah but somehow he
keeps getting away with it so he's
sneaking around the whole time
collecting evidence with what with his
smartphone and unlike everybody in the
games this thing just won't die oh neat
anyway so then the second game they need
to play is that that's
cut specific shapes out of honeycomb
candy without breaking the candy oh
yikes so then ghihan figures out that if
you lick the candy that helps a lot so
he survives with like a second left
which is kind of his thing oh solving
problems by licking things as tight i
never want to hang out with you so then
the players realize that if they kill
each other during the off time that
improves their odds of winning how do
they realize that egg what so then at
bedtime when the lights go out it gets
super violent players are gonna die oh
yeah a whole bunch of players are gonna
die and possibly a couple of epileptic
viewers at home as well very cool wait
what was that last part and then the
next game is a tug of war where if you
lose you fall
oh geez yeah so pretty much all the main
characters are on one team and then a
bunch of random people are on the other
oh man i wonder what team is going to
win i will get this the team with all
the main characters wins oh yeah the
team with all the random unimportant
characters we don't know that team
doesn't win oh man i did not see that
coming very unpredictable for sure i
mean i gotta say though like the fact
that this show managed to have that
first like real cliffhanger mid scene
was that episode i believe that was
episode four and then it concludes in
episode five and for it to be that just
gripping and intense even though you
know they're gonna win yeah the show's
done such a good job at the desperation
and law so far that it has you just
wrapped up in the emotion and immediacy
of it that it does feel just that
intense despite the fact that you're
like well if i just pause to think about
it yeah gonna win
you can't lose every single character
we've gotten to know in one fell swoop
that would be a boss move though yeah
these korean shows and movies man
they're dark so you they would they
would gladly go all right we're shipping
our focus to these new characters so
then after that they're gonna play the
marble game what's that one well
everybody has to pick a partner right
and then they find out that with their
partner they have to play whatever
marble game they want and the loser dies
oh no so there's this ali guy who's just
the sweetest man you know not the
brightest but super loyal oh man yeah
that sounds like a great guy yeah so he
gets betrayed and shot in the head and
dies oh ouch that hurts right here and
this girl from north korea bonds with
someone seemingly for the first time in
her people it's very nice oh that's nice
wait no one of them's gonna die yes so
then her new friend gets shot in the
head and dies oh i don't like how this
episode makes me feel and also gihon has
teamed up with this sweet old man and he
ends up having to take advantage of this
man's dementia in order to survive oh
boy okay
that's a lot it's just for the record
john i want you to know that if we were
in the marvel's game i would undoubtably
make sure i would yeah i know you would
i wouldn't hesitate i would only cry
if an attractive woman was nearby
so they understood the conflict yeah of
course
so they could comfort me afterwards any
game you tell me we're playing i'm going
to agree to play but i want you to know
that
i wouldn't hesitate to destroy you in
such a game that's fair even if it was
100 on the line it's okay you can have
my marbles greg
yeah that sounds right and so then after
that game the vips are going to show up
the vips well they're these super rich
elite types and animal masks and they're
here to watch the games and bet on them
well why are they just showing up now
well you know how when people go see
like sporting events they always show up
just moments before they end that's not
accurate and so i was thinking in terms
of the vips it might be cool if you know
writing and character and acting wise
they all just you know came close to
ruining the whole show just bring
everything down several notches i
thought that might be fun i guess so
then for the next game they need to
cross this super long bridge with pairs
of glass panels each made of tempered
glass or regular glass oh and they need
to try to step on the tempered glass
with every step exactly there's no other
way they could get across what are the
panels held up with some long beams on
which they can definitely cry
by the final game there's just the main
that's the name of the show it is one of
the rules of this game barely matters
because they're pretty much just going
to fight to the death
oh wait is that a factor i haven't
actually listened to many reviews on the
show or got him i've just only heard
nothing but love from the ether of
social media and memes and praise and
that this show was seen by i think one
trillion people yes right was that a a
complaint about that that episode
because i i really like the finale uh in
total but i i the common consensus with
any show was that a portion of the
audience was like man i was really let
down with that finale and i think
especially with the build up to the
squid game being the finale i thought
like keeping it about the emotion or not
about the game was really strong but i
could also see the factor of man this
should start off with making me go crap
i don't know if i could keep up with the
squid game rules
recapping the squid game rules to then
go we're not really playing squid game
it seems like yeah i've been playing a
little bit it's funny i haven't heard
anybody complain specifically about that
different aspects of like the twist and
the finale but just the yeah the fact
that it ultimately becomes is them
fighting to the death now oh fascinating
good enough but maybe
i'm sure we can find a complaint yeah
and his friend ends up killing himself
so gihon wins oh he does and that cop
finds out that this secret masked guy
who's like running the whole game it's
actually his missing brother wait how
long was his brother missing oh well see
he missed his last rent payment so
that's what sent the cop on this search
this guy's running a massive secret
organization and he doesn't have a
system in place to pay his rent that's
what we're going with so then the cop
gets shot in the shoulder and falls away
use all the prize money to pay the
families of the people that die no he
doesn't do anything for a full year he
just goes back to the life he was living
doesn't spend any of the money what
happens to the debt he had with the loan
sharks unclear well okay then oh yeah he
didn't touch his money at all yeah they
don't bring up anything with the loan
sharks maybe the loan sharks came and
they were just like man you just look so
sad that's enough for us oh that's so
fascinating yeah there's nothing ever
mentioned about that it's funny unless
they factored it out or maybe he made
some money on his own and paid them off
he watches right back to the racetrack
and won all the money he needed you
obviously could have paid him off at
some point but they said he didn't touch
a set so then somebody from the squid
game organization wants to get in touch
with him because it's weird that he's
not spending the money at all how do
they get in touch with them by having
somebody sell him a rose that has a
secret little card in it the main thing
they know about him is that he's not
spending any money at the moment so they
get in touch with him via a transaction
that's right that works for me so then
there's gonna be this big twist where we
find out the guy who started the games
is that old guy oh i thought he was
killed during the marble game ah but see
we didn't actually see him die so he
must have had the guard like fire the
gun next to his head or something and
gehan wasn't watching what if gihan
hadn't turned his back how did he intend
to fake his death i don't know fair
enough so then we find out the whole
reason this guy started the game
very fair oh and why is that yeah he was
bored oh
okay and so then the old man dies of a
brain tumor and gihon decides to use the
money for good nice and hair dye what
and then at the end it seems like maybe
he's gonna try to take down the games
instead of taking care of his daughter
oh okay and so that's about it what do
you think well it sounds like a good
series you know and you think we can
properly translate and dub this thing
from korean
maybe
[Music]
oh no oh what really i don't know
anything about the other koreans that
would be going wrong or like what they
missed yeah and the translator i know
people don't love the uh english voice
cast but uh yeah i didn't know the
translation was that i just can't i
can't i could not bring myself around to
even consider watching the dub
one part of it was like maybe the dubs
that was hilarious he knows how to point
out plot holes that are not only thought
provoking but also make it hilarious at
the same time he's he's the best ryan
george follow a screen rap picture
follow his personal channel that thing
isn't blowing up he'll pass screen rants
numbers one day all right guys thanks
for being here you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell hit that like button hey we will
catch you guys soon
[Music]